this Project's been a year and a half in
the making it's how long it's taken this
is one of the most technologically
advanced studios in the world it's
massive it's the size of a city block
you know we're not saving the world if
we met animals in the world so let's
have a good time and uh I appreciate you
all
[Applause]
um
big day today you know why we're going
into the studio to rehearse for the
first time together money Court
so what we're doing is we're going in
the Telemundo studios here in Miami
we're going to work together in a studio
Katie and Anna and I have never worked
together before so this is a big deal
we've done a lot of rehearsals on Zoom
just like everybody else we're going to
rehearse a case for the first time just
to get the feel the ebb the flow the
whole thing tomorrow we're going to go
through real cases so this is you know
getting ever closer this Project's been
a year and a half in the making it's how
long it's taken
[Music]
I have somebody
hey how are you happy we missed you we
missed you we missed you at dinner last
night sorry I've been trying to make you
a TV show oh yeah that happens
no I haven't it's my first time
some of the nicest people I've ever
worked with seriously okay so this is
awesome control room just so you know
okay how many hours I just look inside
there for a second it looks pretty high
tech isn't that nice yeah that's good
it's very slick
and then your room right here great
we'll have it all very nice
look I've got my gummy bears yeah you
can't go wrong with that
it's definitely terrific let me take it
a set okay
we're still tweaking it's looking good
oh nice let me introduce you drive
director Jeff hey Jeff how are you I
never go under this thing
this is it
all right beautiful on camera yeah it
looks terrific
nice
how are you
that's terrific
[Music]
so the way this whole studio thing works
is
um we don't start taping until 10
o'clock but I got to get here at seven
in the morning why that's just TV burn
three hours doing nothing but actually
doing a lot I got to read the previews
of the cases I got to go through makeup
I got to go through wardrobe you know
particularly on the first day you don't
know what you don't know and that's why
you gotta here you get here so early now
whatever the shoot I'm supposed to go to
It's supposed to end at seven that's not
going to happen it's going to go late
for sure let me show you something this
is Studio J this is across from the
studio we're working in now this is the
studio where Jayla rehearsed her
performance at the Super Bowl they made
this whole thing up to look like the
Super Bowl and she worked on it for a
long time to nail it right a lot of
bands before they go out on tour come to
Studio like this to rehearse and get
their songs down before they go out on
the road
just gives you an idea of by the way
this is one of the most technologically
advanced studios in the world it's
massive it's the size of a city block
it's absolutely huge now what happens
dressing room wise is that hopefully all
the Wardrobe is there it's already been
steamed it's ready to go but I'm going
to put on makeup first
before I put on my suit
and yes the Wardrobe is here that's good
see that here we go
into makeup
now obviously I don't have to do a lot
of hair work
these these co-hosts have a lot of hair
to work with so they have to spend a lot
of time doing their hair you know like
hours hours that looks pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the show runner well the big guy well I
mean really yeah absolutely that's the
thing
so this is the guy that's running the
show here but I mean there's also a show
runner that's underneath the guy that's
running the show I mean what is the
pecking order anyways you yeah awesome
look at that isn't that great this guy's
such a politician I can't wait to tax
him that's going to be fantastic I'm
very happy that we've come this far and
everything looks amazing
to me everybody just helping us so so
much get this together and um we're
gonna have a great show I want to have a
good time I believe have a good time
when you're making television you know
we're not saving the world and we might
add a little smile for the world so
let's have a good time and uh I
appreciate you all
right
foreign
[Music]
so let's get right to it and start
resolving these money cases right now
right you know that was our first
rehearsal we've learned a lot about how
to block this show but we've got to make
some changes obviously what I want to
get is more kind of the the rolling
feeling of how it fulfills together and
I the only way to do that is just keep
rehearsing rehearsing rehearsing to get
the kind of the ebb and the flow of how
it works also we're going to adjust the
set a little bit here because it kind of
feels a little different than we thought
it would I also want to move the
prompter to a different place so it kind
of works a little better on the flow of
the show it's all about flow
particularly in a new show you don't
really find your Rhythm until you're you
know you're into it it takes time it
takes time but the amazing thing is
about you know shooting TV is
when it's really working you don't even
notice the cameras anymore you're just
right into the story and that was
starting to happen here today so I know
we're on to something pretty good here
and we were just rehearsing but I was
getting really in to it and so I like
that I know this is going to work out
it's terrific it's a great feeling it
takes a long time to get in the groove I
keep saying that over and over again but
it does it really does because we're all
working on this thing for the very first
time but watch in a couple of days how
it just starts to click
that's what I love about making TV
if you like that video where do you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe
[Music]
foreign